Tark Johnson spent 22 years as a capitol
police officer on January 6 he says he
was in charge of securing the
certification of the presidential
election so he was right in the middle
of it if anyone was Tark Johnson was
here's more of our sit-down interview
with him
Miss Johnson thank you for joining us
and thank you for having me so from the
outside here's how it looked we now know
that huge parts of the federal
government were aware that there was
going to be something big happening at
the Capitol on January 6th they knew
they were going to be big demonstrations
there
and they prepared for that but the
Capitol Police on which you served for
22 years did not seem prepared at all
and of course that would be the front
line in preparedness was the Capitol
Police prepared for that day the front
line officers and supervisors were not
prepared for that at all when you said
so you had no idea it was coming we knew
that there was going to be a
demonstration that day but we had no
idea that we were going to be facing
what we face on that actual day so
things start to fall apart people stream
in the building you call upwards in the
command chain help me you don't get a
response what do you do next so around
two o'clock it may have been a little
bit after two o'clock
I hear a officer say that the capital
was breached so I ran inside of the
building
I ran you know to to assist I knew that
um that location of where the that first
breach occurred was near where the
members of Congress would be locked in
we initiated a lockdown so that means
the chamber doors on the Senate side of
the house I would lock so that means the
members of Congress would be safe inside
that those locked rooms yes so I ran
over to the house side first to make
sure that those those were locked then I
ran over to the Senate side to make sure
those doors were locked so I asked over
the radio and I say something to the
effect that
um we need direction we have hundreds of
people inside of the building what do
you want us to do we need some direction
I got I heard no response
no response so you know um at that
particular time how could nobody
responded nobody responded at some point
you put on a Maga hat
yes now um I think we have it I think we
have the actual magazine yes we actually
do have the mega hack I have it here in
plastic so here it is
um I'm going to take j6 it says High
label the j6 so tell us why you put the
hat on and how that was related to your
suspension that's what got me national
attention was the wearing of the mega
hat they were officers that we had a
distress call that they were
um approximately 10 or 11 officers I
can't remember the exact number were
trapped at the top of the Rotunda steps
so
um I elicited the help of some CDU
officers to help me go up the steps and
I kept yelling that all the way up stops
giving people high fives trying to make
it up steps to get to the guys and as I
was going down there was a um
demonstrator on I believe he was on my
right side of me so he reached over I
didn't know what he was doing I didn't
know if he was going to hit me and he
put the mega hat on my head so um so as
I was still trying to walk down the
steps then he asked for the hat back and
I said well I would like to keep it
because like is you know the hats want
to help me that's your pass sport
through the crowd yeah exactly so the
capital places by definition nonpartisan
it serves both parties in the Congress
it protects members of both parties 100
and it has to be that way in the wake of
January 6th you saw
what looked like partisanship
at the Capitol Police did you perceive
that I'm still shocked because as a
capital police officer we even had a um
we had our chief of police at the time
his name was well um Steven's son and he
um he called for a all the officers who
was at work that day he called for
everybody to come in and we all went to
um we all went to emancipation Hall in
the CVC and he and this is doing um the
black lives matter demonstrations yes
and he told us that as capital police
officers we need to stay neutral we need
to stay neutral period so
um we're like you know okay that's
that's we do we know because we protect
Democrats we were Tech you know
Republicans we protect everybody so we
need to stay neutral so then after
January 6th
um you had
um
some police officers who wasn't neutral
it didn't seem neutral at all yeah and
that was an issue yes
so I mean that devalues the credibility
of capital police doesn't it if they're
allowed to be partisan in public they're
supposed to be neutral period since you
were there on January 6th what did you
think of the job of the January 6th
committee do you think that they were
honest in the way they approached it do
you think they got to the truth I pray
almost daily that they would get to me
um I was never asked to testify and if
you listen to the you were never asked
by the January 6th committee he's never
asked by anybody connected to the
January 6 committee to testify I asked
myself why every day
um and every day I might have a
different answer but um I you know
looked at what pretty much they focused
on Donald Trump and not the failures of
the Capitol Police why do you think they
were there I think that some people
there
had planned on being violent some people
may have turned violent after what they
were going through I think that um
people wanted to support their president
they wanted to some of those people
wanted just to support him and some of
those people didn't commit violence and
some of those people didn't plan on it
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight